I grew up in a suburb of Detroit
Farmington Hills Michigan I am the
youngest of three and the daughter of a
Lithuanian father and a German mother I
was a big geek
I loved my classes I loved studying I
loved learning and also understand being
the daughter of an immigrant that work
ethic is something that was instilled in
me when I was finishing up at Hillsdale
I knew that I wanted to work in the
music industry so my choices at that
time were either New York or LA and I
moved to Los Angeles with sixty three
dollars and a smith-corona typewriter
and I am not joking I was offered an
internship with a legendary songwriter
Desmond child Desmond was the mastermind
behind the songs for Bon Jovi and
Aerosmith and Cher and Michael Bolton
this was this time period he is one of
my greatest mentors he sold over 300
million albums when he was moving his
operation to Miami I wanted to stay in
LA
and he said you're gonna start your own
company and I had nothing mind you but
what I did have was some knowledge from
Hillsdale where they had discussed being
an owner versus being an employee and
not only in a business sense but being
an owner of your own destiny I was
always asking my clients okay tell me
what's the story before we would go into
an interview before they would write a
song I would say okay tell me what's the
story let's really distill this down and
then one day one of my music clients
turned to me
okay so Petty's what's your story and
the truth was I knew part of my story I
knew that my father was born in
Lithuania and that in 1940 the Soviets
occupied the country I did not know that
it was estimated you know that over 14
million people lost their lives in
Siberia so I decided that I wanted to
tell that story and the idea came pretty
quickly one girl her dream of freedom
and a voice to speak for these millions
of people who never had a chance to
share their story and that became my
first novel my first novel had a lot of
interest to be adapted into a film so we
shot the film in Lithuania imagine the
thrill of seeing a story that you wrote
come to life in the most beautiful way
the film is full of hope and hardship
and strength and struggle and now we're
meeting with distributors and and
submitting to film festivals and so I'm
really excited being honored in this way
by Hillsdale College is indescribable so
much of who I am and what I put into my
work comes from things that I learned
when I was at the school and comes from
people who I admire so deeply it's an
incredibly humbling experience
and I hope I can continue to learn and
grow and create work that moves people
and that people feel is meaningful